ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show special edition no glasses
today I because I'm not high on
oxycontin when I wear the glasses it's
because I'm on heroin as some people in
the comments have pointed out that I'm a
junkie and I'm wearing neglect not
because the lights burn my eyes and I
have a tick I have an eye twitch MTS
motor tick syndrome where I sometimes my
eyes roll back people go are you having
a stroke or do you hate us and I'm like
no I have an eye tick this is just what
it is it comes out when I'm tired or
whatever
um or when I'm angry and I'm a little
perturbed I'm a little bit not crazy mad
but I just did a show at the comedy
store and I don't like to speak bad of
anything or anyone
that's a big part of what I avoid here
is not trying to speak bad about anybody
or anything or any club I ne have I ever
spoken negatively about an institution
no and listen I like the police many
good people at The Comedy Store like the
cops many good people are there and
they're just doing their job like the
people who put Jews in camps just doing
their job but I did a Tim Dylan and
Friends show
which I we saw that in about 30 seconds
and I and the Tim Dillon friends show
what it is is uh you you your friends
whoever's there Spade who's ever in town
Greg Fitzsimmons who's ever around Annie
who's ever around comes and does the
show it's not a big deal it's fun people
come out they see it I go on last and
it's fun and the
first of all like the night before
they're texting me they're like what's
the lineup who's what's the lucky you
have a lineup do you have a running
order do you have a lineup or a running
order who's gonna get on this stage
who's going to the other hey hey hey hey
hey we sold the tickets relax
yeah I have a lineup it's everyone you
banned they're back
so
I'm I'm doing this delicately
Jordan's Lobster Island Park phenomenal
so I'm sitting there my godson's family
comes in my godson whom I love my Godson
my my godson's fathers was a fan of the
podcast who I didn't know super well but
decided because I'm single gay and
without a family that if he made me the
God Son of his son I would give the kid
money in the form of a college fund
which I do
which is it was a good move if you know
someone who's wealthy and doesn't have
children of their own just go you're the
Godfather they showed up once in my
house in Palm Springs I said come on out
we'll have a lunch they came out with an
Asian baby and said you were any there
was a note written saying uh Uncle Tim
will you be my godfather
and I had you know what I mean I just
bought like the Range Rover so they were
like
and what are you gonna do it's like a
little baby if it was a white kid I
would have went yeah but he's Asian he's
high-end top of the line top of the line
his family brings him in to the Green
Room his mother's father
and the baby and it's a wholesome event
the baby's running around he's doing
whatever
we're all you know what I mean
halfway through
I don't know who these people are now at
the com The Comedy Store is now hired
people that used to work at San Quentin
the prison
and
I don't know what's going on over there
okay
but
they've hired like these big hulking
brutes
these like log bloggers they're like
it's like guards they're like guards and
it's and and and nobody knows who anyone
is and nobody knows who I am I'm like
I'm the one who's put to sold the
tickets to the show
so they're like
at least Rogan's Club there's Navy Seals
they have actual Authority
they've killed people on behalf of the
government I'll listen to them who are
these people so they have these hulking
brutes walking around okay
and one of them and again
this is all nice and respectful
this is respectful this is the resp
trust me it's a respectful rap I'm I'm
sitting in the show that I've sold out
at the comedy club could have done it at
the Improv could have done it at the
Laugh Factory could have done it at
Flappers could have not done it could
have not done it could have not done it
could have done it at the comedy
Mothership which I'm doing on Monday
I'll go right down to Austin with the
guns we got the guns
okay
so I'm sitting in the Green Room
uh some actor kators friends with me
came or is it like a new friend of mine
but he's and I think he's on the heroin
or something but that's okay that's all
right it's not a big deal
he came in with his friends he was some
other dude he's like where's the
bathroom they just both went into the
bathroom so I'm like well they're
sucking each other over doing heroin it
now it's gonna sound like I've done the
wrong now everybody's gonna side with
the club I haven't even gotten to the
part so there was a little shady
behavior that I had no idea I just I
invite people sometimes that are famous
kind of right they're kind of famous I
don't know what they're doing they're on
heroin maybe they're on oxycontin
whatever I think they're crushing up
stuff I don't it's not my business
but that's not even what they're mad at
so I'm sitting there
and then the hulking brute comes in
and he goes the baby's gotta go
oh excuse me he goes the baby's gotta go
now
he's gotta go he points
at my Chinese two-year-old godson and
goes the baby's gotta go now
he's gotta go now him
so I go wait what's going on
what's he doing
and he goes well it's a rule we have a
licenses and Nightclub he can't be here
it would be a 500 000 fine and I'm like
really
really because he stopped in in a green
room
really
don't you have lawyers
does no one have lawyers here
but whatever I would have respected the
idea that you can't have the baby in the
green room because they just stopped in
again they're stopping in to say hello
I would respected that idea but it was
the way it was delivered it was the way
the message was delivered this weird
like aggressive posture
that they take by the way a lot of
people produce shows there I talk to
Luis Gomez about it all the time they
make you feel like a criminal when you
produce a show at that club they make
you feel like a criminal maybe that's
part of the fun
#mothership the point is this I was
sitting there I have a Chinese person
you [__] white devil who works in a
comedy club Whitey I have a Chinese
child The Golden Child have you ever
seen that with Eddie Murphy that great
thing where they got to balance himself
on the beams and then drink the water
and the fire goes out maybe you should
start thinking about the [__]
prophecy so whatever somebody I don't
know I've never seen this person
apparently they work at The Comedy Store
they were probably like removed from
Enterprise Rent-A-Car for attacking a
customer and now they are doing the
security of The Green Room
uh and and kicking out everybody who's
under 21. that's new energy huh so the
point is we're having fun
now
so he goes the bit the big the baby's
gotta go
I'm like okay I'm sitting there I'm like
the baby's gotta go
so then the baby goes then the baby
doesn't care because my godson wanted to
go to Mothership he told me he goes I
want to go to Mothership he's a huge fan
of Schultz and I go no but come to the
come to The Comedy Store we have
comedians who've been doing comedy 75
years
and he goes it's gonna be fun so
so my Chinese godson is evicted he's
kicked out of the like literally the guy
stands there he stands there until the
child is picked up
and he like walks them out
and the booker comes in who's sweet I
like who's a nice person he's a sweet
woman a beef with her but she's there to
like I guess smooth it out or like and
she's like well yeah it's like
[Music]
his baby
and I'm like
okay okay fine fine
this kid Justin who's a young comic in
L.A
is in the Green Room he's a funny kid he
was big on Tick Tock and then they
banned him for like making fun of like I
don't know the tick-tockers that have
pull it's like Addison Ray or whoever
these people are the demilius called
China and got him kicked off Tick Tock
they call presidency but he's like a
nice kid and he's a young guy and New
York being from New York again I'm from
New York like somebody told me we were
sitting in the green room with the
Improv the other night and they go
uh is it embarrassing that you moved to
Austin and move back I said no no I hate
I don't care about anyone here I don't
respect anyone here and all of this can
burn truly I don't love Austin but all
my friends live in Austin and New York I
don't give a [__] about this place at
all and it could all burn and it was a
little awkward I was in The Green Room
with other Comics but that's the way I
feel I like like six people here kind of
so I don't care so the reality is I'm
sitting there and
yeah the reality is I'm sitting there at
this kid Justin's there and I said to
Justin I'm like yeah do a guest spot you
know he can't that's what I in New York
if somebody comes and hangs out you give
sometimes you'll throw them a guest spot
it's like the right thing to do it's
like a good thing to do you know what I
mean now apparently this is like
confused
the people at the club who are like
who who's he and he looks young right
he's a young kid he's like 19 or 20. and
he then
one of the one of these prison guards
one of the corrections team asks him how
old he is and he goes and he's a little
bit of a wise ass he's a comedian he's a
wise ass
um he goes I'm 13. it's funny it was
funny and then the guy goes show me your
ID he IDs the guy
in the room
that's the energy of that's the vibe
there it's like it's like a strange Vibe
then I get out and and start to do
comedy now they had a show at 10 and
they lit me like five minutes into my
set
which is weird and then I still pushed
it I did probably 20 minutes what do you
think I did 20. I did 20 minutes I would
have done longer but it was like a weird
there was a weird energy and a weird
vibe not with the audience they were
amazing but they lit me so early into my
set that they were kind of like we have
a
we have a 10 o'clock show and I'm like
that's great you have a 10 o'clock show
but it's also like nine I got on at what
9 15. yeah right it's just like if I'm
off stage by 9 40 we should be able to
flip the room you know
um so again
I just don't I didn't and it just
happened it's the only reason I'm
talking about it it's not like lodged in
my mind I don't care
um I'm just saying I didn't love the
vibe do you think I was wrong my
reaction with the vibe there was odd
they approached you in a pretty
graceless way it was a weird way to do
it it's a weird way to do it it wasn't
cool at all it's odd it's just strange
don't make me go down to Texas get the
guns
come back with the guns I just don't
understand the behavior the show is at
10 30 actually so they they booged you
45 minutes early
it's a city where everyone's incompetent
and no one can work so that apparently
people need 75 minutes to switch foot
the room
how do I do it
and raped a table
hey
[Music]
he's got to go the baby's gotta go now
the baby's gotta go you've got a Chinese
baby in here he's a spy
they're hiring like cooks that got like
removed from Denny's because of like an
altercation that's the energy you know
and I'm sure they're all lovely people
I'm sure one of my friends column
comedian from New York compelled at each
other made some joke about like a
waitress or whatever that didn't go over
and maybe calm did the wrong thing I
don't know he's Irish like me maybe
there's a little anti-irish buzz don't
love that
it has a little anti-irish sentiment but
column supposedly somebody walked up to
calm and went I want to curb stomp you
one of the staff was like I want a curb
stop you
again I told the Lewis Gomez about we
all love the store it's a legendary
historic place but it's weird when you
produce a show there and you're treated
like a criminal
odd weird hands it's in weird hands it's
strange and I'm not making a big deal
out of it I'm just saying what am I not
going to talk about it I'm speaking
about it because I want to but I'm not
making a big fuss I'm just saying it was
an odd moment when you're screaming at a
toddler
in The Green Room
the only thing they didn't
bring up where's the the actors doing
dope in the back bathroom which
that is
something that I you know I don't know
I don't even know if that was happening
I'm kidding but I don't I don't know
that was the only thing they could have
maybe brought up you had a couple of
kids who had heroin back there
I would have went I don't know
they're not my God children
honey
today's episode is sponsored by honey
it's an easy way to save When shopping
on your iPhone or computer thanks to
Honey manually searching for coupon
codes is a thing of the past honey is
the free shopping tool that scoureds the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best one it finds to your car imagine
you're shopping on one of your favorite
sites when you click checkout the honey
button appears and all you have to click
is apply coupons the easiest thing in
the world and it does save you money
wait a few seconds as honey searches for
coupons it can find for the site if
honey finds a working coupon you'll
watch the prices drop
I love honey because I used it and the
thing for me is that it's easy
that's what I like
so many things are hard and when you try
to use them you start crying and hitting
things because they're difficult and you
don't understand them they make you
angry and they make you afraid
but with honey it's so easy the honey
button I forget it sometimes I'm
checking out and I'm buying something
and then the honey button pops up and I
go
oh my [__] god
did you did you have a coupon for this
and they do
and they do it in the price drops and
you literally watch it with your eyes
you go huh
honey doesn't just work on desktops it
works on your iPhone too just activate
it on Safari on your phone and save on
the go if you don't already have honey
you could be straight up missing out and
by getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting this show get
PayPal honey for free join honey.com
slash Tim D
AB join honey.com Timmy literally I use
it now I do save on stuff I check out
it's easy there's no I mean there's
nothing what do you have got to lose
what are you nuts
get it I love cereal and the most
important thing about cereal is that
it's healthy and the great thing about
magic spoon cereal is that even though
you think it's a sugary cereal like the
one that you ate when you were a kid
it's actually very healthy for you and
people love it it's delicious it's high
quality magic spoon is replicated your
favorite childhood cereals to taste good
but each serving contains zero grams of
sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein and five
four to five grams of carbs per serving
the Honey Nut flavor contains one gram
of sugar but it's worth it it's keto
friendly gluten-free grain free soy free
a way to relive those moments watching
your favorite cartoons I remember
childhood plus it's only 140 calories in
a serving it's amazing with over eight
unique flavors you won't get bored of
feeling good with magic spoon my
favorite is peanut butter but I love
them all blueberry muffin cocoa fruity
frosted Maple waffle honey nut cookies
and cream cinnamon roll birthday cake
doesn't it sound like Health Food Magic
spoon
my first experience with magic spoon was
when I tasted it and then I was like oh
my God this tastes good
go to magicspoon.com Tim Dillon to grab
a custom bundle of cereal and try the
magic for yourself I'm dead serious
folks you're gonna love it your kids
will love it get it for the kids put
your kids on keto now
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com Tim
Dillon and use the code Tim Dillon to
save five dollars off that's
magicspoon.com music code Tim Dylan to
save five dollars off
what's Gwyneth Paltrow doing now stop
bothering this woman she tried to kill
someone in what she was skiing and
they're making her pay Gwyneth Paltrow's
attorneys by the way what is who
Gwyneth Paltrow
daughter of man suing Gwyneth Paltrow
over Street ski crash tells cord he was
emotionally abusive this is what's
really good when is Paltrow was skiing
down a hill and like
knocked into a guy who's now claiming he
has all these problems right and then
they got his daughter to go on to stand
and trash him
it's great to have money like Gwyneth
Paltrow that's goop money she has that
store where she sells insane products to
people
like a candle that smells like her [__]
someone said once I forget but somebody
said it's similar like the infowar store
like with just like she look like things
on the infowar store will be like this
is the ward off demons and her thing
will say the same thing
um
the Civil Trial between Gwyneth Paltrow
and Terry Sanderson
entered day two by the way can you
imagine
like this try like it I don't think it's
a jury trial because it's civil but it
may be it might be
I mean how fun would this be to just be
on the Gwyneth Paltrow
ski trial like what a great trial to be
on because nothing matters you know what
I mean
whoever wins like they're both pieces of
[__] like and I'm sure she's a lovely
person
disclaimer but like her like you don't
feel bad for Gwyneth Paltrow right and
you don't really feel bad for this
scumbag who's trying to like blame her
for whatever he's has now like Parkinson
whatever he's like claiming she gave him
the Civil Trial between Gwyneth Paltrow
and Terry Sanderson entered day two on
Wednesday and the room heard how the
retired optometrist was known as quote
emotionally abusive and quick to anger
prior to the 2016 incident
lawyers for the oscar-nominated actress
That's essential huh lawyers for the
oscar-nominated actress read a testimony
which was provided by Terry sanderson's
daughter Jenny Sanderson during their
cross-examination of witness Dr Wendell
Gibby
the radiologist had earlier testified
that Mr Sanderson 76 had a strange
relationship with his family following
the accident in the Deer Valley Resort
in Park City Utah which is hilarious
that that's what he's claiming he's
claiming that the injuries he's he's
suffered made him a piece of [__] to his
children he's like well I when one day
Gwyneth Paltrow by the way who's what
all of
what is she 170 like 50 pound like
supposedly she knocks into the guy and
he's older so probably you know she's
got velocity behind her but then he's
claiming that he just started like not
caring about his family
I love so here if you go up here it says
that like during his cross-examination
attorney James Egan questioned whether
Dr Gibby was familiar with the claims
made in Ms sanderson's deposition which
had called her dad domineering and
easily frustrated
her testimony claims she did not feel
loved or nurtured by her dad before also
describing how he was verbally abusive
towards her and her mum according to Mr
Egan Miss Sanderson said her dad had
always been frustrated and quick to act
I love that the daughter is testifying
against the father like the fathers like
Gwyneth Paltrow knocked and knocked me
over at a ski resort since then I've
been unable to be a father to my
children and then his daughter gets on
the stand and goes you've been scum
forever you've genuinely been like a
horrible father since the day I was born
Miss Anderson also told her dad how she
didn't have a relationship uh she said
that they never had a relationship like
for 13 years they didn't have one
Dr Gibby told how he couldn't recall
details of the deposition but did say he
knew of Miss Sanderson being angry with
the man
said to be having an affair with his
wife wait Dr Gibby told how he couldn't
recall all the details of the deposition
but did say he knew of a Mr Sanderson
being angry with a man said to be having
an affair with his wife this is such an
odd case
because it's a guy who's claiming that a
ski accident made him like weird and
distant around his children
it was claimed Mr Sanderson had hit the
other man but Dr Gibby said he thought
this Behavior was atypical of the
plaintiff earlier Dr Gibby told the
court Mr sanderson's relationship with
his family had only gotten worse after
the crash he also said the injuries
sustained by Mr Sanderson could not
plausibly have been caused by him
crashing into her the trial by the way
what a worthless trial what a worth what
even is happened like how does this get
into the court system what a worthless
insane trial I like if I was impaneled I
would love it because I've got nothing
going on I don't care but like if you
had anything real in your life you know
and you had to listen to this [__] every
day like two people at a ski resort
I mean God help us the trial is expected
to last up to eight days
and Gwyneth might testify
she was looking somewhere else blindly
skiing down the mountain while looking
up this was Reckless Mr Sanderson is
seeking damages of 300 000 for a brain
injury for broken ribs and other serious
injuries Miss Paltrow meanwhile has
fired a counterclaim in which she is
seeking legal fees and damages of a
dollar
it's really one of the stupidest things
to ever go to trial 300K is nothing to
her she's just doing this for the point
she could just settle with him for
something
it's such a I mean I love this Gwyneth
Paltrow's ski Collision trial enters
third day
can you do you think the Judge at any
time goes hey hey like the middle of the
Testament goes hey hey hey hey what the
[__] are we doing here
what is going on
I can't deal with this anymore we're
trying to ban Tick Tock this is wild
they're trying to get rid of tick tock
because it is a tool of the Chinese
surveillance State and not the American
surveillance state they're trying to get
rid of tick tock the one where everybody
dances
because they're saying that uh China
bite data I think bite something that
owns Tick Tock and The Tick Tock CEO
Xiao Chu
was grilled by lawmakers
and they say tick tock's like the
biggest problem it's the bad one they're
like this is the bad one unlike Facebook
which my aunt went on looking at
casserole recipes and is now full Q Anon
and estranged from her family that's the
good sight
that's the site that doesn't have any
problems Facebook
where people are eulogizing their dead
dogs
and threatening members of the
government on it
some of that's probably a little
Justified but
Facebook is truly I've never seen
something as damaging to America than
Facebook
Tick Tock it's hard to get radicalized
on Tick Tock because it moves so quick
so it's kind of just like a baboon next
next next
and it just feels like it's kind of
silly and what social media should be
and I know people have become big stars
on it a few of them and people use it to
Market themselves and yes there the
Chinese are spying
that's also true but you know we're also
spying
so people are trying to get rid of it
tick tock itself is not available in
mainland China and we're headquartered
in Los Angeles and Singapore and we have
7 000 employees in the US today he said
in his opening remarks this is the CEO
he was basically like listen because I
think what we're trying to do is like
force maybe more U.S ownership of tick
tock
you know
because it doesn't operate in China
and the Chinese government like enjoy
significant leverage over businesses
that are under the jurisdiction of China
and bite dance which is not bite data by
dance
so thus indirectly Tick Tock could be
forced to cooperate with a broad range
of security activities including the
possibility of the data on Tick Tock so
what people are worried about is the
Chinese government harvesting the data
from tick tock
and using it
to I don't know
I don't truly know
like President Z is going to be sitting
there going who's this Bryce Hall
what's going on with uh the the tick
tockers versus YouTubers fighting
just gonna win what do you think but
apparently it is I mean there's location
data there's facial recognition data I'm
not blind to the idea of this it's just
a little late the cat's out of the bag a
little bit everything you use every
single thing you use
takes all of your data takes all your
information
every single thing people upload the
photos of their families their houses
every single thing
sometimes in a Facebook fight or
something like a guy will be like this
is my location come meet me come meet me
I'll kill you
I'll kill you because we're having an
argument about charter schools
so why don't you show up to my house and
I'll kill you here's where I live here's
my address
Facebook should be banned ban them all
but Facebook should go
Zuckerberg should and he goes in front
of Congress all the time and they're
like what are you up to and he's like
well I I think that
what we're trying to do and then you
could tell you could tell it's just way
over his head he didn't know he just
wanted to get his dick wet and now
Russia and everybody else is on there
everybody's on there you know The Oath
Keepers the three percent every militia
in the world's on there with the
Facebook page my aunts in all of them
probably but like I've seen people get
truly radicalized on Facebook
uh so if they're gonna get rid of uh
tick tock
to get rid of this thing which I don't
care because I don't really have any
followers on Tick Tock but uh Tim J
Dillon on Tick Tock go follow it but I
don't really do anything on tick I tried
I tried I'm 38. what am I gonna do I
tried I tried for a little bit
it's just not you know you gotta tap out
at a certain point you gotta tap out you
don't like this don't watch
that's all there's nothing you know what
I mean like there's a certain point you
have to tap out like I've seen I get it
and some of them do well some of the
older people on Tick Tock do well but
you know it's just not a it's an app
that's not for
people in the in their heading towards
40. it's not an ad for people coasting
towards 40 in my estimation it's just
not it is fun it's a lot of cringe stuff
on there you could look at a lot of
crazy people doing [__] the algorithm is
addictive yes it's addicted our kids yes
you know it's not it's probably not
overall it's probably not good what's
good what's the good one is Instagram
good with women with the five needles in
their lips
is that the good one is that the one
that's good for the kids where people
shaved their [__] pictures into like
they crop themselves into aliens and
then kids try to try to look like that
what's the good one Twitter
is that the good one
where everybody's fighting about
everything all the time or Facebook
where Boomers
who are having operations
and are somehow still alive
are like
going through a Litany of like it's like
casserole recipes and like blatantly
racist you know
[__] tirades about their neighborhood
the cab driver was Mexican again or
whatever the hell like is that is that
the good which one of these is good
again because we have to pretend one of
them's good if we're gonna kick this one
off we have to be like whoa it does it
it's not as classy as uh the Instagram
or uh I just don't know
[Music]
um
somebody goes like this to the American
people watching today hear this Tick
Tock is a weapon of the Chinese
Communist party to spy on you manipulate
what you see and exploit for future
Generations there's probably some of
that happening
but I don't I I you know at the end of
the day it's like yes is this a long
game to weaken the American yeah maybe
but it's like hey man we're doing a
great job of that we're doing a
phenomenal job about ourselves that
doesn't mean you shouldn't monitor this
[__] or whatever but then you have the
Senators like what is this thing
does this have Wi-Fi
what exactly is Mr Zhu Ching Zhao
Ching Chao Zing Zhu tell me what your
company does are you watching my babies
change
are you turning them in from are you
turning my babies into my my man into
ladies and my ladies into men's is that
what you're doing let's watch this guy
here I love bespoke posts because I like
giving people gifts that keep on giving
and what bespoke post is is you get a
box for somebody box of awesome and then
it comes every single month to them and
the boxes all kinds of unique things
that they're into and whether it's for
you or a friend you fill it you take a
quiz and then the quiz could be like
they're gonna basically be like what are
you into and you could be into
Outdoorsman stuff or being a bartender
like drinks and Cocktails or food or
cooking or all kinds of stuff or
Athletics or whatever and the box of
awesome will just keep sending you
really cool stuff based on your interest
and it comes every single month it's one
of the most fun things
I give it to all my friends because it's
a good way for them to remember me and
every single month they get a box 90 of
everything that comes in your box of
Awesomeness from small up and coming
brand it's free to sign up and you can
skip a month or cancel any time so
you're not like locked in to the 12
months okay they release new boxes every
month across a ton of different
categories to get started take the quiz
at boxofawesome.com your answers will
help them pick the right box of awesome
for you one box of I took a quiz and
then box of awesome just sent me net
like nail filings like it looks like
people's nails that people had bitten
off their nails and it was just a box
with knit with nail filings in it and a
lighter that didn't really work but so
that's interesting I don't know what I
said in the quiz that Iris got that
but but it was like one of those things
where I was like they kind of know me
box of awesome.com enter the code Tim
donut check out this box of boston.com
for 20 off your first box box of
awesome.com code Tim Dylan
does tick tock access the home Wi-Fi
network
yeah only if the user turns on the Wi-Fi
I'm sorry I may not understand that so
if I have a stick talk app on my phone
and my phone is on my home Wi-Fi network
does tick tock access that Network
it will have to to access the network to
get connections to the internet if
that's the question is it possible then
that it could access other devices on
that home Wi-Fi network
Congressman that we do not do anything
that is beyond any industry Norms
um I believe the answer to your question
are you getting to the toaster or not
can it [__] with the toaster yes or no
I'm asking you a direct questions
let me ask you a question
our kids were doing great before this
app came along they were shooting up
schools and doing heroin
at least tick tock's getting them to
dance
at least tick tock's getting the kids to
I'm not saying it's a good
but it's it's funny that like we're
blame it's again it's China it's always
Chinese people the Russians or the
Chinese every problem in America has to
do with Russians or Chinese people
nothing has to do with American
government parenting value systems
everything is something that came from
China or Russia to [__] us all up
everything was going great with the
American Youth before Tick Tock
everything was going swimmingly well
with America it's not our education
system which is a joke it's not a value
system that you know tells kids that
money is that you know all these new
influencers that's what Ethan Klein was
talking to one of them debating one of
them all these like crypto influencer
kids who are like 24 and they're like
they're into Jesus but but for a little
time they talk about God for a couple of
minutes and then drop shipping for 90
minutes like it's primarily Drop
Shipping a little bit of God and it's
all about like it's like you know I made
millions of dollars [__] Drop
Shipping and [__] for God
that's for God that's why I did that
because God was like [__] do you get
your you go to the gym and get and we
you know great go to the gym but like
this this new thing now
we're like our children are becoming
like Psychopaths we're like watching
these kids become like sociopaths
they're like God told me to trade Luna
and I did and I have seven cars like
Jesus said and you're like okay so again
and maybe that's maybe that I don't know
but some people like that some people
think that's good they go well that's uh
you know the tick tock is uh helping our
kids it's helping our kids become
motivational speakers
um I don't know I don't know I'm not I'm
not saying that tick tock's a a
universal good okay
the Tic Tac CEO is like hey this is
nothing we just want to go to war with
China we're just trying to go to war
because our economies are like literally
the the news last week was like
um oh the banks are
banks are not
banks are not it anymore folks they're
going down the banks are and then this
week they're like the problems China's
tick tock
that's the problem and Tick Tock I'm
again I'm not defending I don't think
it's a great idea to have kids on social
media all day I don't think that's a
phenomenal move right like I don't think
it's great like but I also think like
this myopic view where we look at like
this company and say this is corrupting
our children and ignore the poison food
and we ignore like so many other things
and again I don't care ban it I don't
have any followers
it doesn't [__] boss it doesn't
[__] bother me you can all [__]
dump in podcasting don't pay in YouTube
don't do that
but
I love the things that they think like
universally good you know I like the
universal good you know I don't know
it's like
so Tick Tock collects I think roughly
the same type of information as Facebook
and Twitter that's what they claim
they're saying like hey
you know that's a lot of like data it's
the information about the videos you
watch comments you write private
messages you send
and
so here's what they think it's doing get
play the kid out who identifies as a
hawk this is what
this is what they're worth they think
that China and by the way maybe China is
doing it I don't know they're they're
saying that China is
pushing these weird
theories or whatever so this is why they
worry about people getting radicalized
on Tick Tock this is a person who is I
don't know if this is real
I don't know anymore I don't I don't
know what is and he isn't real anymore
so if I play this and then you comment
this is actually a practical joke I'll
go life is a practical joke I don't know
anymore this is a person that is
claiming
to be I believe a hawk which is kind of
cool now what people are worried about
is maybe they think and maybe this is
true China is making our children in
talks
so let's watch this
my name is Horus and I'm a red-tailed
hawk in a world I do have the body of a
hawk but while fronting I consider
myself a Therian because I am in a human
body but my identity is still a hawk not
all animal altars will identify this way
and I am in fact the only animal alter
in our system who does identify this way
I am doing my best to come to terms with
living in a human body
okay
um is there anything more about this uh
this user they have a lot of like Neo
pronouns so let's watch a neopronoun
post okay here we go
here we go listen
we're learning
[Applause]
I like this
don't you kind of want your kid to be a
hawk
wouldn't Republicans like that like like
hardcore right-wing people Mark he's not
trans they're a hawk
it's not great that many of our children
think they're Hawks but I don't think
that's a lot of them but I will come out
and say that I will I will say this
right now
and I don't think this will be a
controversial point and yet I'm sure it
will be I don't believe it is a positive
development in our society that some of
our children are under the impression
that they are birds
[Laughter]
that is not a positive development
in our society
um
there is a lot of mental illness on Tick
Tock and I'm sure it spreads very easily
just like there's a lot of mental
illness everywhere on all of these apps
and I'm not I'm not saying that this is
all you know great for the kids
um you know again
let's watch some of the other because
maybe I'm jumping to conclusions here
about the hawk
okay let's try uh this one
how common is it for systems to have
like splitting patterns like our system
and at least one other system that we
know of have patterns of like there will
be a few or several splits at once and
then a period of time where there's none
or very few and then another bunch of
splits all at once is this normal China
doesn't understand this China doesn't
even get this China has no idea what's
going on let me tell you right now
the Chinese government has no idea what
this is if
if you play this for president Z
he's gonna go what the [__] are they
talking about
this I don't know if this is being
engineered by China I don't know what
they are probably like what the [__]
because I don't play that again I don't
even I can't even grasp it
how common is it for systems to have
like splitting patterns like our system
and at least one other system that we
know of have patterns of like there will
be a few or several splits at once and
then a period of time where there's none
or very few and then another bunch of
splits all at once is this normal
how common is
I think she's talking about like the
splitting of like ideas how things
there's like binaries maybe
does she mean like people's personality
split after like extreme trauma and you
could like become multiple personality
disorder maybe it or maybe she's just
like going super Broad in like all
Concepts how there's yes and no and
light and dark what the [__]
what the [__] is going on
I don't know
all right ban it I guess
I changed my mind
all right ban it
no I thought it was just people going
like this
I didn't know I mean they'll just go
somewhere else and do this I don't what
is the commitment to the like the
commitment to this is so
wild like the commitment to this
these the Neo pronoun thing it's just
it's so it's some doesn't seem fun like
the hippies in the 60s were like we're
[__] we're doing drugs we're rolling
around in mud this is like not fun
they're not fun I know what Neil
pronouns are thank you I'm aware of what
they are I don't have to bring them up
but and it just doesn't seem fun
you'd think being a hawk would be more
fun than that I am a hawk
it doesn't seem fun like isn't how fun
being a hawk
I am a hawk not animal not all animal
Alters will identify this way I mean by
the way maybe they
kick me off
maybe they are just enjoying themselves
is this is this maybe a way to have fun
play a video where they're having fun
there's got to be some is there one
thing where they're smiling
there's got to be something where
they're having fun being a hawk's got to
be fun right
the Disney the Disney filter one this
seems fun
[Music]
all right let's not I don't wanna yeah
yeah their tick tock's gonna get blown
up or whatever I'm sure because this is
going viral I'm not doing this yeah but
that's what they want they're killing it
good for you
to tax impact on children a key point of
focus
New Jersey Democratic rep and member of
Mafia Frank
ranking member of the committee for
example said Thursday research has found
out that tick tock's algorithms
recommend videos to teens that create
and exacerbate feelings of emotional
distress
including videos promoting suicide
self-harm and eating disorder well this
is a problem and I've talked about it I
have a bit kind of about it on stage
where a lot of girls started acting like
they were um
they were they had Tourette's because
they were on Tick Tock there was a bunch
of girls that like had like Tourette's
they pretended to have Tourette's and
then the doctor told their mother your
daughter is a liar
she doesn't have Tourette's it's fake
and then they had to take that car ride
home from the [__] neurologist
and the mother had to be like really
really
you're faking that you have Tourette
syndrome
at you're just screaming the n-word at
breakfast for nothing because you want
to have friends
that's a slur
now
lonely kids that have problems
uh go on Tick Tock and apparently they
see some really good can we find any of
the tick tocks that like promote
this type of stuff like self-harm or
something because
yeah you want to see like the Blackout
Challenge or something like that what's
oh yeah because these I forget about the
challenges right so the challenges will
be like lick you the inside of your
toilet
I'll give you a warning when you search
it
get around that
tell them we want to die
get around that warning
so these challenges are really
destructive to kids
um and this is what people are really
upset about because
here we go one example is Tick tock's
Blackout Challenge encouraging its users
please
can you go back oh that's it
so The Tick Tock Blackout Challenge the
families of two girls so
both ledge did both girls died from
self-strangulation
after they tried to partake in this Tick
Tock challenge the Blackout Challenge
which reportedly encourages its users to
choke themselves
with items like belts ropes purse
strings into the business so this is
interesting all of these challenges like
where are they coming from
maybe they're come are they coming from
kids or
are they coming from like Bad actors
State actors
like is China doing this is trying to
like let's see if we can get the kids to
choke themselves
I don't know maybe they are but I don't
know
or are some [__] crazy kids putting
out these challenges and then other kids
are going I want to be cool I want to go
viral
like can we watch the Blackout Challenge
please yeah
here we go first one
this kid's like a child
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
he's not even blacking out
he's breathing
he's cheating
you're not supposed to breathe
you're supposed to Black the [__] out
can our kids do nothing right
[Music]
I don't see a problem with this
I don't see a problem with a kid on the
side of the highway trying to make
himself pass out
four views
I don't
kids have rights of Passage when we were
kids we used to throw
eggs at a Bally's which was a gym in
Long Island and people would be working
on the treadmill and we'd throw eggs at
the glass
um at the glass window and the people
would like just see the eggs coming in
and they would work out and we were
doing that
because we were fat activists we were
anti-ableism we wanted to show them
that no but we would but it was a right
of passage like we had a little group
called The somebody's because Tim Allen
did that dumb movie Joe somebody we
stole the sign for the movie did we call
ourselves to somebody it was really
funny a few of our friends were are not
deceased
hey kids I had a lot of fun we had a lot
of fun and we would do pranks we'd throw
like stuff off overpasses on cards and
stuff but not like you know but nobody
ever got hurt I think my friend one time
there was a problem but hey we just
threw we occasionally would throw eggs
it like but it was tough it was fun
pranks pranks like fun pranks nothing
crazy
this is pranks
these are fun this is the memories these
kids are going to talk about like
remember when Jimmy
was by the side of highway to try to
make himself black out
remember that
you know where he is now
he's dead
he died in a car accident
he was drinking
but
he was a fun guy like
I don't see a problem there I don't see
a problem
with American children
trying to black out
for cloud
I think this is like something that
we've all done at some point in our
lives
what are some of the other challenges
because this one's not even I'm not even
I think they have like a teeth filing
one as well
DIY teeth filing this one sure
I'm gonna
I'm okay with this too
do this yourselves it's a tick tock
Trend that's making many people cringe
do it filing teeth with a nail file do
it guys it's literally literally working
wait let me give myself some vampire
teeth
DIY procedure is giving dentists a
toothache when I saw these videos I
almost fell off my chair you know I
think that people have been in lockdown
for uh yeah because they're funny we're
all used to kind of cutting their own
hair Let It Go enough all right enough
listen
I have no issue with this
these kids they're having fun
they're pretending to have Tourette's
to making themselves pass out they're
filing their teeth
they're kids
they're pretending to be Hawks
this is fine dude remember when your
sister thought she was a hawk
and she was a freak
we gotta let him do it man we gotta let
him file their teeth we gotta let him
pass out and die we gotta let him
we gotta let him do it it's our kids
you know we we gotta let him do it
there was another one of milk wasn't
there a milk challenge
that was a good one
if there's kids watching this show I
can't I can't even do this joke anymore
because YouTube keeps age getting
everything
what so but there was a milk challenge
where I think you had to drink a lot of
milk
well the new one now or the one that the
one I remember was like the gallon
smashing and grocery stores
which was just making a mess
the gal oh the gallon challenge yeah
yeah wait wait yeah the drinking gallon
you know we you know we in school once
we swallowed like tried to swallow
teaspoon cinnamon it's so hard
and we'd eat like a teaspoon and then
you start breathing like cinnamon
[Music]
they're kids they're smashing gallons of
milk
they're passing out next to the highway
they're filing their teeth
children
pretending after rats it's a goof this
is fun your kid just sit at the table
you're kidding they're going
[__] [__] N word
dude it's it's fun like stop being so
sensitive about everything
this is the data that China wants
I mean it's by the way if China is doing
this
I mean
it's a little funny it's a little funny
if China's doing this can we get back at
them
why don't but they won't allow it they
won't allow it
but we've done a lot to try like we're
fat we got there's fat Chinese now we're
doing that we got [__]
go to a list of the American fast food
companies in China we're making them fat
and they're making our kids file their
teeth and that's fair
American fast food restaurants in China
let's see what they got oh wow Kentucky
Fried Chicken they [__] love it there
okay McDonald's
Burger King Starbucks
dude
they're we got
I think they got Pizza Hut too
they have Pizza Hut
they got the hot but here's here's my
point we're making Taco Bell China
wow
we're making them fat we're playing a
game too
we're gonna play a game too let's see
how fun it is when all your citizens
just can't get off their chair
let's see how fun it is when you're a
billion people
can't walk
watch
we gotta we we can fight we fight the
way we know how to fight with the
[__] stuffed crust pizza and the
McDouble that's how we fight fight with
breadsticks sauce
dominoes Papa John's barbecue chicken
pizza fight with Burger King
mozzarella sticks fight with Oreo
McFlurries turn them into fat diabetic
monsters
they can come in our teeth will our kids
will file their teeth and pass out and
drink gallons of milk we will turn your
country into fat slobs very easily
very easily that's how we should fight
that's how we should fight
Pizza Hut opened its first store in
China in 1990. followed by Domino's
Pizza 95.
the two pizza chains both expanded in
the Chinese market in the 2000s by the
way that's our covid
that's our lab League
we are putting Pizza Hut delivery Pizza
Hut in China
people that didn't have a lot of food
now I can press a button and we'll
deliver pizza to them so this is the
thing about globalization you get the
good with the bad right
you get the good with the bad so that's
the fight
that we have to bring to their Shores
folks I'll be on the road doing uh stand
up comedy
not in La kidding kidding
I'm not trying to start beef I'm just
saying enough already respect the
Chinese children
Raleigh
this weekend Prior Lake Minnesota Grand
Rapids Michigan Englewood New Jersey
Huntington New York New Brunswick New
Jersey Peoria Illinois Kansas City
Missouri Portland Oregon Tacoma
Washington Palm Beach Florida North
Charleston South Carolina Hershey PA
that's with Shane Gillis Nick Mullen Jay
oakerson I mean what an amazing [__]
lineup insane
Chicago Milwaukee San Francisco Bensalem
Pennsylvania
and then
that's it
so I mean I don't know what what's left
to say here I mean I don't know where I
stand on this now I came in very hard
for not Banning Tick-Tock but now I've
seen some of the damages damaging things
that it's doing and I'm kind of on the
fence about it I don't know I'm gonna
ultimately say no don't ban it because I
know people that have made a living on
it
um
and I think if your kid's a hawk you're
gonna have to deal with it you're just
gonna have to deal with the fact your
kid's a hawk there's a lot worse things
your kid could be than a hawk like a
teacher
your child was a teacher yeah my kid's a
teacher oh we're real proud
uh teacher yeah he worked real hard for
that
uh so I'd rather my kid be a hawk
I'd rather that than say my kids a
teacher I'd be like yeah my kids are
mentally ill Hawk who filed her teeth
down and passes out on Tick Tock and
she's killing it she's got five million
followers and she smashes gallons of
milk they and they smash gallons of milk
and they file their teeth down and they
black out
at a [__] at a whim they just black
out that's the type of kid I want a
[__] Tick Tock Beast no I mean listen
at the end of the day
what an interesting way that countries
are now fighting each other you know
like they're really aiming at the youth
and they're I mean I I don't know if
this is State actors doing this I guess
it might be
but I also think it's just weird I think
it's weird if you just give kids power
kids do really [__] up [__] now they
can spread it around the entire world
they do crazy [__] and they're like look
I did this [__] you could do it people
want to go viral the promise of virality
of Fame of all this [__] it corrupts it
does it's a bad value system right it's
not we don't we don't but we don't we're
not building anything on a solid uh
value system for our children you know
so I I do see why people are concerned
about it and you know it's kind of out
of their hands your kids are gonna have
iPhones you're gonna be in college I
mean they're going to be in a high
school or college they're gonna be on
Tick Tock and they're gonna be [__]
you know they're gonna be
exposed to all this stuff you hope that
I guess you raise them so that they can
fight The Temptations with this stuff
because it is very sad when
the kids do these challenges and then
they die before they've even seen how
many followers they've gotten
that's the saddest thing and that's what
I would say in the eulogy I'd go
she died
before she knew she was trending
[Laughter]
she died the hawk flew away
before she knew she was trending
as always I will do direct deals on the
road I'm on the road now and I will do
direct deals with Muhammad bin Salman
the Saudi government and the Chinese
government if they want to sponsor my
tour
I have no interest in dealing with
middlemen I would deal with the Saudis I
will deal with the Chinese directly
Putin directly if they want to sponsor
my two I do appreciate everybody who
buys tickets we've had a lot of fun new
dates in West Palm or May 5th through
the 7th bus Palm is always so much fun
it's just people that just left the
queuing on Boat Regatta is there anyone
more fun than that they're fun they're
fun and they write about some stuff and
wrong about other stuff but they are fun
and um we appreciate uh all of you all
the time Tim Dylan comedy.com get
tickets thank you